you know the gino that i met on the  internet didn't text to excess it's not  a sugar daddy any of that  and i don't trust you  because you lie about everything  that's not true  so demonstrate your actions don't offer  me material things show me show me  that you're different  i want to that's what i'm trying to do  show me your mail  your email  show me your email  [Music]  [Music]  don't delete  give me  all right  [Music]  he says that he has changed  that he's not interested on dating sugar  babies  and that he  doesn't have anything to hide  but i'm super smart and good at  technology gino so  if he has been lying to me  i'll figure it out  the new emails don't i would just ask  don't  open us because i have to look at this  i'm gonna find something sad you know  what is it  [Music]  you